That's it! We're done! Great job finishing the class. You
might be wondering, what should I try next? I'd encourage you
to have a look at other courses in the data
science track here at Udacity. You might consider taking Intro to
Data Science, Intro to Hadoop and MapReduce or maybe Intro
to Statistics. If you enjoyed this course, pretty much anything in
the data science track is going to be of interest to
you. If you'd like to learn more about MongoDB, we offer
a number of introductory and advanced online courses
on our own platform, at MongoDB University. These courses
cover all the details of MongoDB that we couldn't
quite fit into this course. For example, there you
will see just exactly how we scale MongoDB
to big data problems. These courses are completely free,
and taught in a style very much like the
one you just finished. Take a look at university.mongodb.com.